Number two.
I hear, I hear the sound
of a telephone. Hello. Hi.
Bodies Assembly. A story from
Greg Warner. Yes. Hi Jed.
Greg is a NPRs east African
correspondent. You are in,
what time is it where you are? It's
um, it's evening is based in Nairobi,
around seven 30 in the evening,
which is embarrassing cause I just
told you good morning in Swahili. Um,
but I forgot how to say. Good
evening. So, oh, okay. So Greg,
I mean we were just, uh, anyhow,
we called Greg up because he had written
this article for this great website
called transom.org about being a foreign
reporter and working with translators
and all the mishaps, you know, when you
have to go from one language to another.
But there's actually a really good example
that I didn't use in the piece about
the failures to communicate. I can tell
you that story. Sure, sure. Yeah. So,
so there's this word and you wouldn't
think of it as untranslatable,
but it's the word
serious. And when serious,
serious, serious, like S.
E. R. I. O. U. S. Okay. Um,
in my experience when you hear this word
serious in east Africa does not mean
solemn or thoughtful or stern.
It actually almost never has
something to do with your mood,
but serious tends to mean is,
are you just talking to
me or are you serious?
Are you doing something? And usually
doing is like some kind of transaction,
usually financial. I've been asked
by many east African officials,
are you going to be serious
with me? And it obviously means,
are you going to pay me a bribe?
Usually I pretend to misunderstand
that that key moment I said, yes,
I'm a very serious international
journalists and um,
but the story that I want to tell you,
uh, took place a couple months ago.
Good afternoon everybody. Um,
I'm really pleased to be back
in Africa. Secretary Kerry,
Addis Ababa visited Ethiopia and city
have enormous energy and the country.
Few days before Carrie's visit,
nine journalists had been arrested under
this relatively recent anti terrorism
law that basically says that any
criticism of the government is illegal.
I had a series of very productive meetings
this morning with my foreign minister
counterparts and secretary Kerry
was giving this press conference.
I shared my concerns about a young
Ethiopian blogger that I met last year,
uh, [inaudible] who, uh,
with eight of his peers
had been in prison.
And I firmly believed that
the work of journalists,
whether it's print journalists or in
the internet or media of other kinds,
it makes societies stronger.
You know, he said all the things you'd,
you'd expect him to say. He said, um,
we believe that free speech and open
dialogue is important to the economic
development of a country,
blah, blah, blah. But
we remain committed to our partnership
with Ethiopia, with [inaudible].
This comment was also wrapped up in a
lot of praise of Ethiopia engaged, and
I'd be delighted to
answer a few questions.
I'm not sure how that's even do that.
Then keep time for questions.
He could took some vetted questions from
the Ethiopian journalists to more from
the traveling press and
to carry [inaudible]
credit. Are you all give this
gentleman? I want to give them a shot.
I know he was very impatient. I'm going
to sort of wait for, he left the podium,
he was like, you know what, we're
just going to try something different.
We're gonna like call on
an Ethiopian journalist.
I want to make sure we get
a fair distribution here.
Kerry pointed this one guy in the
second row, young guy in his twenties,
boyish face wearing a [inaudible]. I
have only two questions for you, sir.
I may have invited the hardest question
of the day now, but one question.
Fair enough. Okay,
so let me choose. Uh,
you have raised the issues of uh,
Nathanael's [inaudible] who is
a blogger and his friends. Yeah.
In Mark 11, and then this guy's like,
well, every time a journalist is arrested,
the u s gives a statement about
this, but these things are,
this keeps happening, repeated,
repeating. Very much so.
Then he asks his question,
is it lip service or are you
seriously concerned about Zerorez?
Is this lip service or are
you seriously concerned?
[inaudible] at this point, everybody's
just not looking at Carrie.
They're all looking at
this journalist too.
Obviously had to take considerable
personal risks in a place like Ethiopia.
In a crowd of journalists, including
state run TV stations. He's,
this guy's on camera asking this extremely
sensitive question about the arrested
journalists. We really demand a
genuine answer from you. Thank you.
And Carrie looks at him
like, well, you got to be kidding.
When I stand up in public and I,
and I, and I say something, uh, I,
I try to be serious about it and I
think the fact that I'm doing that is
serious.
And when I raised him by
name in my comments today,
I can't, it sounds to me like he's sort
of insulted by the question. And so,
so remember serious,
the word serious in east Africa can be
translated very much as are you doing
something preferably like a
financial transaction, right?
And so what this journalist is saying is,
are you just talking about this or are
you doing something maybe threatening if
you be with a withdrawing aid or
withdrawing support? And Carrie says,
I am very seriously talking about that.
We have previously called for the
release, uh, these individuals.
And that is the policy of our
government. And it's a serious policy.
Thank you. Thank you all
very, very much appreciate it.
And it seemed to me maybe,
you know, you can judge,
but it seemed like he
was almost like, look,
I'm like the most serious
politician that's out there. I mean,
I lost the presidential race in 2004 in
part because I was deemed too serious by
the American public, you know,
like, what are you accusing me of?
Not being serious.
We put in a number of requests to speak
to John Kerry or someone in the State
Department, but there was no response.
Do you think he was aware of the
misunderstanding who carry this? Uh,
this felon? Oh yeah, no, no. I followed
him out afterwards. Hey, minute, minute.
Can you pronounce your name
for me? My name is [inaudible].
He's a easy young guy in his twenties
he's an independent journalists. Yeah.
I used to work in different newspapers
and I was like, you know, when you,
when you listen what happened there?
And I almost felt like I
had some kind of cultural,
a guide maybe because that Americans
think serious means I'm standing here.
I'm not joking, I'm serious.
But when African spacey series and
I'm using a generally they say no.
Are you going to not just speak?
Are you going to do, yeah.
[inaudible] that's exactly my point.
Are you going to take sanctions?
Maybe [inaudible] yeah. Do you feel
that that question puts you at risk?
Maybe. Who knows?
Is that is a job description doing
good journalism Muni tape yet.
Thanks so much. Thank you. Yeah.
I'll give you a call. Give me a call.
My number is on there. Yeah,
so that conversation was
about five months ago.
Did do you know what his fate at all?
Let me have you found out why there?
Did he suffer for this
question in any way? No,
but I have his phone number so I
can give him a call and find out.
Hello? Hi [inaudible]. It's Gregory,
Gregory Warner. Oh, good ego.
I'm good. I'm good. Sorry.
I reached him by Skype.
He told me that actually after that press
conference he did get strange calls to
his home and some Facebook messages from
people who didn't know telling him that
he better rethink what he said.
Yeah, they are lying.
Not Too with the current
government direction and that
they said you should line up
with the government's priorities.
These messages were from the
government. It's hard to tell.
It has been reported that this Ethiopian
Anti Terrorism Task Force will wage
social media attacks by getting
people to send messages on its behalf.
[inaudible] John PK reason,
the task force are the ones that
seem to these kind of [inaudible]
and were they threatening? Yeah,
some of them were, you know,
[inaudible] that I would be punished
accordingly when the train comes and it
might come one day
the newspaper he founded got shut down
after publishing one issue and he was
planning for a while to fleet in Nairobi.
[inaudible]
leave his wife and kid behind and
then maybe return grabbed them,
apply for asylum in the United States.
You know,
my mother and my older brother
are visiting U U s Washington.
Oh, okay. Washington.
Like a lot of Ethiopian cs actually got
some relatives in the, in the states.
Did they hear that? You asked
the question to John Kerry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I've heard
that. What did your mom say? She says,
please don't do that. It smells
good. It might be, you know,
got to gating you things like that.
You know, moms are like that then.
Yeah, I like that. Yeah.
So one's [inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible] Tony
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].